siamo nuovamente ritornati sul bisogno
di proprio quello benvenuti su video
correlati grazie giampiero per la sigla
pazzesca ragazzi analizzando sempre le
vostre proposte per cercare appunto i
video correlati di oggi partiamo che
quella del titolo perché secondo me
secondo me merita da maria de filippi a
wii sports io non so come potrei mai non
ho idea
[Musica]
maria de filippi allora innanzitutto
maria de filippi è abbastanza sempre per
che tempo che fa e ce l'abbiamo perfetto
adesso d'acqua arrivare a wii sports
sono i video correlati me cojoni allora
usciamo la chiave della rai che sono
tutti correlati del genere magari
andiamo dove mentre del gaming che
mentre nel gaming non so neanche come
tra l'altro nel gaming hold quindi
ancora peggio drive di possibile joker
dal vivo joker dal vivo
ringraziando iddio perfetto grazie joker
che file alive veri momenti giusti
allora e fino a qua ora siamo entrati
nei geni quello che avrei nel gaming
della uil non idea di come trovare un
intentarono sa idonea come viene in
mente come diavolo finisca idonea anche
io sono abbastanza di intenda lo è però
chiaro chi è che fa i video di we se the
ever man set
ever ma devo trovare ciò che giro fare
so che giro farlo a fa vj valigie e
c'era prima fa vj grazie dovevano solo
abbiamo trovato il gancio da me in
qualche modo ci arrivo fa vj fa vigenti
come ora devo trovare il video di the di
five four di rilievi five four che è
difficilissimo da trovare ma lo trovo
allora aspetto ab cliccato il nostro dj
perché darsi dei fan formiconi collega
assente permane settimana ha fatto una
roba di wii sports una voce della uil
poi da wii wii sports e facile devo
trova mamma mia che giro pazzesco
eccolo qua mi piace ho messo sei anni
per mi è spuntato devi fare adesso
adesso dovrebbe uscire nei quadrati
ovviamente dei di five four sperando di
dio
peccato dei vip ago force devi fare un
fornito la cuccìa devi five four days wi
fi go for davy five four ho cliccato su
dave i file folk uscirà degli five four
days before perfetta
ok adesso dobbiamo andare sulla pelata
reveal che il video dove va fatto
applicato nel tagliarsi i capelli poi è
spuntato sete aver mai che poi anche a
meno anche ain debba sky possiamo fare
effettivamente da questo lo ritrovare
così siete aver ma tantissimo eccolo qua
ho fatto dei giri pazzeschi dove in
genere allora ci siamo da trovare solo
il primo video che vidi di seta eccolo
qua ce l'ho
questo il primo video che ho visto solo
da qua dovremmo esserci tiro fatto
ragazzi ciechi pazzeschi
teoricamente wii sports qui sport quindi
lui teme siamo nella gu il weekend team
tema ragazzi a e questo e wii sports
vale il titolo non c'è wii sports
forcole vogliono dai ore 6 sport
maurizio non vale a dio
berger che giro ragazzi che giro bravo
però è da maria de filippi era difficile
and so on esso
è questa io non so veramente come fare
prove da dame tuco sita a mairo
accademia vabbè dai
[Musica]
ho perso prove siamo su da me tu così ta
e non ho idea di come arrivare ai agli
anime anche perché siamo nel loop delle
musica del suo porco demonio ogni volta
quando è difficilissimo uscire dal loop
della musica ragazzi c'è veramente
perché poi adesso dicono sia tutta roba
musicale tutta roba musicale quindi
niente vediamo allora da cocco che non è
unanime dove andare sul giappone in
qualche modo per derek frozen dai
qualcosa di animato giapponese di
qualsiasi tipo come si esce dalle
musiche porca vacca cerca di beccare gli
animi e partendo dai film è veramente
difficilissimo ragazzi o veliche voce m
di tensione mv madonna volevo trovare
solo quello di ma ero accademia che però
avendo visto solo tre puntate non lo
riconosco non mi linciate l'avete del
nome di unanime nel titolo che cacchio
non c'è il nome di un anno
[Musica]
la strada da anni tu così tamaro che la
mia non era facile anche perché eravamo
gli sviluppi delle musiche quindi sempre
rimanendo in tema musica siamo arrivati
lì mamma mia quante ne sono da poltrone
sofà a robert downey junior
io non so io no io no io non so
[Musica]
siamo su poltrone sofà quindi voglio
capire da qua devo andare sulla marvel
ma come ci arrivo a marvel trovo non ho
idea di come arrivare ai supereroi ma
non ce lo prova anche per sbaglio devo
andare avanti finché non trovo poi
eccolo the seas visi universo è già
qualcosa
batman aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
che quando abbiamo beccar iron man e che
qua al casinò a deadpool thor buono
buono buono già buono io vado giù nel v
avengers the iron man e iron man ce
l'abbiamo abbiamo captain america civil
war e attenzione quindi ci siamo però no
sono finito nell'altro dei film ha messo
tirato dentro
ok ho aperto il film vero c'è il trailer
prima che mi esca da rob e adesso mi
consiglia sole film non valera che non
esco più qua non esco più perché mi
consiglia solo film porco demonio
sbagliato ragazzo torna indietro perché
non ho perso o penso perché non posso
andare avanti perché adesso vi consiglia
solo film non puoi uscire non puoi
uscire consiglio ha solo film quindi
niente turn all indietro di una penalità
una mezza vittoria facciamo che 9
dominate 2 questo sarà un mezzo perché
non posso purtroppo cliccare su un film
sono ho perso è pieno di roba d oro per
dalì junior ma non c'è robert downey
junior nel titolo quindi è impossibile
perché persiste nel titolo robert downey
junior è proprio quello il fatto tony
stark potrò fare al potere su fattori
stark era meglio tirate talmente
difficile da scrivere dove robert downey
junior che la gente non lo scrive è
sopra quello siamo tutti i tony stark
[Musica]
ma dorme che casino è stato ragazzi un
cristiano che abbia scritto robert
downey 1
la donna ed introvabile abbiamo da
rosita ha ovviamente pirati dei caraibi
[Musica]
noi siamo su con rosita siamo con
banderas teoricamente dovrebbe cibi
giorno
ok d'azzurro da zorro d'azzurro zorro
dovremmo uscire dal giorno a pirati dei
caraibi da d'azzurro zorro tutto sto
casino non sto trovando niente di banche
per che però arriverà pirati mica lei
che cosa devi fare devi che ha fatto
pirati e gara non è robert downey junior
quindi johnny depp orlando johnny depp e
orlando bloom oscar qualcosa fogli osca
fino adesso abbiamo giocato bene dai
siamo a due e mezzo almeno un 3 e mezzo
lo facciamo zia caterina da aldo
giovanni e giacomo in qualche modo ed il
padrino da aldo giovanni e giacomo in
qualche modo mi collegherò a pirati dei
caraibi non so come ma lo farò fuori
capitan jack sparrow jack sparrow
no dai raga perfetto questo quasi quasi
record quasi
bellissimo perché da aldo giovanni e
giacomo
il meglio di pirati di capitan jack
sparrow che era perfetto forse record
addirittura può essere la quasi comunque
dai bella partita brava di tre e mezzo
ho recuperato il mezzo di prima siamo a
4 questo vale uno e mezzo dai più fatto
un partitone facciamo le regole un po
come vogliamo dai meno che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi questa è la video
correlati 4 fatemi sapere qua sotto cosa
posso cercare nelle prossime riprese
video di video correlati cercate di
essere abbastanza ingegnoso sia mi
piacciono le cose che non centra una
sega l'una con l'altra cosa che non
penseresti mai cosa del segno più
l'accertamento è un mi piace iscrivetevi
al canale e come sempre ci vediamo hanno
passato le ragazze
[Musica]